[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Joe I told you no fetches on this show
yeah but just five what happened Don
what about that far how many you pull
out there tonight
tell me lift up that hole in the second
act didn't hear what's the matter
didn't you like it I get it repair the
way the audience took in I thought it
was funny funny
you couldn't make me laugh no matter how
good I thought my lady makes me nothing
a better
[Applause]
are you mr. Melvin yeah I'm Bonnie King
especially damaged but she's gonna be
here yesterday yeah yeah that's a no gay
girlie
well we'll see what you can do hey play
something snappy try this video is done
[Music]
bunch of edges especially dancing yes
then why you're doing a cornice routine
the course fat again
[Music]
hey remember that train leaves at 11:45
[Music]
I gotta eat
hey I came all the way from Chicago to
this job and you ain't you to be a fair
break for a sec I stopped playing at
Temple you'd have to help Saint Vitus to
keep off living
and this wisecracker whether you stop
velvet across the stage what's she
raving about just horikoshi can't make
the grade don't be too hard on the kid
give her a break I'm paying afraid on
too many Rummy's without taking on
anymore
you're out the [ __ ] that too
I'm ticking you gap and trying to feel
it out though for you so lay off you
don't need to get tough about it
first of all the cheap outfit back to
the district is the worst
well you can't fight with me over there
have an all-night and working all day
respectful Furillo like no you can see
what happened to that poor little kid
tonight Oh big ape
there she is out there huffing the [ __ ]
peach banging away at the pianist and
best marketer I still think it was a
thirty roughly trick listen mr. Joffe
where do you get off telling me my
business
well somebody ought to tell you
something about how to run a show
anytime you don't like the way they show
run you know what you can do bet I know
what I am doing alright
you're a through Saturday night not
sweater Dino right no give me my dog no
you owe me those I do
not according to my figures adult
according all mine all right
I'll even let you get a Hollywood set
you up okay see you later folks
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Kim what are we doing here oh I got a
date with a spicy food yeah are you that
thinking engine couldn't get up enough
steam to pull the whole load so I got
off no I quit
I'm hungry
it's not the Billboard just now effect
can I give it the once-over
gee it must be great to be on the big
field traveling and sleepers and playing
all the regular theaters I wish I could
make the gray you can I caught the last
act of your show tonight
if I knew anything about show business
you were too good to be true with that
bunch of hand
you wouldn't kid me would you lady I
would if I could mr. I what if I could
see Miss Alyssa
what's your name Bonnie anything mine
skid skid Johnson hi it's true
[Music]
say you really think I could make good
on the big wheel sure is a featured
comic why not you're clever
I knew thank you why that guy and you're
out of a job it's both wire yeah but I
ain't got your talent ah rats with your
face and figured maybe you could make
good anywhere there's nothing at this
racket let me show you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey we could fix up a swell routine and
North to one sure it'd send off that
wire
[Music]
[Music]
in there you do it
what's your salad when you better make
it easy make it 50 bucks
hey this is a big wheel don't think
you're any good try to make it a hundred
hey wait a minute okay don't pay that
kind of dough
beside they don't know me well how about
five all right I'll take a chat yeah
Sanok
hey Elmer on Rogers a useless
well partner we done it yeah but we
ain't got no answer yet
you think they'll throw us out
Oh waiting for it painted
[Music]
[Music]
say I proceed you both run now between
us and scaring me to death you know you
gotta hurry last act on Jimmy give the
fireman's job I can dress like dollar
pole be getting some to eat nah I wasn't
hungry oh no I wasn't thirsty either Mac
the show tonight I'm gonna take you to
the hotel and she did you get something
decent to eat all right honey
oh yeah yeah i beaned about you last
night
you did get me wet in the who's girl
no you were on Broadway I want and you
were not gonna sue the fish for gold
leave it gave me a kid I don't believe
in dreams but I do this one keep it so
real I've been thinking about it ever
since
big I better wire Ziegfeld that I've
decided to let him star me and I'm
bringing you along as my leading lady
with me or without me it's Broadway for
you you just get some ambition no bun
when you talk like that I almost believe
it
maybe then it's gonna come true you
wouldn't kid me would you lady yeah what
if I could mr. I would if I could
I guess we know what these means I'm
sorry kids but you know how business has
been and I've got to cut down on the
overhead well don't apologize Lexi it's
all in the game
I hate to do it but [ __ ] it out of
court response fires almost Fathead you
called principal
come on Jerry I guess I'll have to go
best my husband
come on honey it's time for tricks
[Music]
Oh baby you look frightened that no
costume knows me actually no you always
look wonderful to me honey I guess
that's why I never mentioned them
[Music]
[Music]
hey Marco the way you focus on him
anybody think he was falling for you all
mind your own business with you I will
if you will get wise
so ain't no body force kid but bunny Oh
go fry yourself your big piece of fat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
taken in cold don't worry about me kid
I've eaten corn off the cob when you're
shaking like a vibrator
the thing I ain't I can see a human is I
[Music]
the normal believe God
the best is to keep your lines straight
look at those jobs maybe you keep off my
face anytime look at you you'd be happy
let's get that I want steel I'll be with
you in a minute honey don't be long
you know we got a date for the night
before what's on your mind well you know
it's get business has been terrible and
I've got to cut down on expenses so I'm
letting several people go see that's uh
yeah well most of them I've got it
coming home but I sure hate to let
Bonnie out funny yeah yeah I know but
you see honey and me well well we're
partners
well I wouldn't give her notice if I
could figure out any possible way to
keep her you know that's good yeah I
know but listen Lefty if it's all the
same to you keep Bonnie on it and take
it out of my salary to me anyway well
alright yeah yeah but listen when
business picks up you gotta kick back
with it oh sure getting an earful so you
can stir up some more trouble you are a
troop melodrama
run along fat lady before some sideshow
Stasia this up so yeah that's so say
it's that frame you hang your clothes on
and anything to tie into I chuck you one
just for luck fire away
Declan within fat pause your your car
why you come out Gussie don't you get
enough exercise when you tied up with
that balloon
let me effect
you leave my wife alone you know she's
got a weak heart you know I didn't have
the heart to slipper the notice though I
left it under a cold cream jar and
wonder if she found it oh honey when are
you gonna stop taking those fall well
they're in the plot ain't they
yeah but why worry about the plot nobody
else does and even the guy it's just a
tip on her own horse
so you're playing the ponies again well
this is a hard one
yeah they're always huh what no no this
is right in the old feed box did you
promise
well all right tear it up
yes yes here about lefty cutting down on
the payroll
he's lettin several people go no Jesus
shame
of course you stay thanks it's kid
what's good guts do it oh nothing
only you have to cut out some of his
luxuries now that he's paying your way
what do you mean by that crack ass kid
if you don't believe me now what are you
trying to do stir up some more dirt and
see a Swiss kid
yes why he just fired off me and ducked
out for a couple of cup of he just left
drunk last night drunk the night before
going to get drums tonight again if I
never get drunk no more
yeah
five o'clock five o'clock
[Music]
you know it's 1:30 what do you mean by
waking the guy up in the middle of the
day would you be late for the maddening
I found out the name of that - of course
you will been afraid yeah very shocked
sure I'm quitting the show ah ha ha you
can't do it then have you paid my salary
yep
woah look but don't you see we're
partners ain't we
and then we teamed up together and we're
figuring on having our name in lights
someday so what's the holler if you were
in my place together
I know what you do so I'm gonna do the
same if we bond it
hey bunny I've been taking over what
what you said back at the hotel
you really mean what you said about
and it'd be different if I had a
favorite someday we'd get married you
know I'm crazy
will you marry me tonight with you'll be
getting the worst over I'll probably
leave you a heck of a life I love your
plan honesty
[Music]
what do you say
[Music]
Oh
he wouldn't give me what you lady how
what if I couldn't if I could
[Music]
repeat these words after me with this
ring I thee Wed and with all my worldly
goods I thee endow
at this range IV IV with Heidi went with
all my worldly goods I thee endow
and thou the MOOC is flat broke I hereby
pronounce you man and wife
for better or for worse till death do
you part
may I extend my congratulations and wish
you a very happy existence
well I'm I'm glad that's over are you
happy huh yeah you mm-hmm
oh I'm gonna try and make you happy
always buddy
I am happy if I ever give you any reason
to think otherwise
well you a holler well it's all over
ain't yes it's a lovely ceremony isn't
it yeah I think it's so much nice to be
married by real minister than a justice
of the peace
mr. Clarence there's the white X Thank
You mr. Johnson well I guess that's all
come on I guess we'd better be back on
the hotel me well I'm one of the clan
now left to you thanks again just no
weddings don't you bozos yeah I've seen
some pretty good funerals too how you
feel dear I've been through it man a guy
in this business is some responsibility
to be prepared for shock
now all that be it straight now for a
little Willie yeah yeah yeah there it is
actually 1000 and honey all star Junkins
Hey oh wait wait kid give her a few
minutes alone I'll be with you in a
minute honey
hey I got a bottle of pre-war Scott and
I've been saving for just like tonight
is it out boy you won't have it long
I've been married good many years and I
mama you good now what I want to see you
do want to be fixed up just waiting to
go into burning well you're gonna get
dirty
stay on all night good get them married
let me look at you
what I want to tell you now that you're
married
is it yeah how long you been married me
I never been made
imagine that apron above well may all
your top
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey Sandow
let me try that strongest part of you is
your conversation hey come on Dan I'll
pick that up without moving your hand do
it this one all right oh this must be
good now oh you want me to fall down hey
what diet you smell one two three
why don't push
well I got away from the getting all
right I will in just a minute
you owe me is a farmer's child I can
undress light another poll
I'm sorry bunny wait a minute I got a
how many give you our two weeks notice
we're quitting the show within the show
me and skip what you can't do that one
there wouldn't be any show that skid
yeah there will be no skid he's fixing
this outfit much longer
yeah but you're just kidding you you're
too good a trouper to bow out of the
middle of a season nothing for the love
of what I'd have to close my show think
of the other people you can't do that
well we will stay on one condition
what you people have all got to promise
to quit drinking the skin
all right bun
but I can see where skin is gonna have a
heck of a time from now on
oh hey don't you think I know that the
only wise thing he ever did was marrying
you tonight I hope you're right you're
his one chance but I'm for you
let us see you again every time we play
this town I wonder if you're gonna be on
the show
bought tickets for every performance
this week give my best regards my name
change and sure like the beaver sure I
will he's goofy about funny every time
we play this town he's out in front
every before
[Music]
[Music]
your channel Kings out front again what
a seat for every performance just like
he has for the last three years you know
I think if I ever brought him back to
meet you he'd know there was a heaven
we're bringing back lefty you do only
following your ever had alright Oh
let's get heard anything from New York
yet no why
well Ziegfeld was agent was in at the
matinee right after skids big number he
beat it across to the telegraph office
he's in again tonight are you trying to
get a rise out of me Lefty
no honest I just kid over against this
big opportunity that you're always
raving about he's got you to thank for
it me sure I hope he gets it you're
entitled to a break you're a swell guy I
will not see you a little Balad detect
the I diluted oh well what's the
difference
it was written especially for me by the
sheer numbers don't want to play yeah
I'm not seeing it in the native tongue
no no don't you know it the onions
[Music]
[Music]
down in a pool some of the gang talking
of pearls they do
women are all the same set Joe
I'm busy bird hell ain't you heard the
story
and get an earful
she was a dame in love with a guy she
shtup to him
didn't know why everyone blamed her but
they all named her
[Music]
he gave her nothing she gave him all
that's when he had his back to the wall
[Music]
save him
smiled and forgave him
[Music]
and he got a bank went away to get a new
start but kid she never got a break
except in our heart maybe somewhere in
heaven above there's a reward or that
kind of love angels won't blame her they
too will name her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you would have a contract to do your
cutters don't be discouraged Jerry honey
baby sighs woman yourself well of that
rich you could swallow a couple of the
president wouldn't change your shape
none say it ain't so Jerry say it ain't
so
lucky for you you're leavin tonight with
other people to take one good punch at
you
thank you late a silkiness before train
time matter what I'm look at that scroll
a frame of yours shocked New York as it
is well mountainous I'm planning to
leave this show without staging a battle
but I don't take to that last crap of
yours no well what are you gonna do
about it
I'm gonna take one good socket you to
see how soft you really are hey wait a
minute don't get excited
you better pee discussed here I'll be
late for the ferry no what is it an
elephant ass when I come back I'm gonna
chase you or did you find six new
streets
what are you doing
get in here oh nothing I was just saying
goodbye to Gus II guess I'm in the wrong
ring and before you go mom I just want
you to know but you didn't put nothing
over me you know what I mean I'm not
staying be insulted
you're staying like I'm white spaghetti
but get it skin better since we deny
you've been trying to get him to drink
thinking maybe I get disgusting what am
i new perhaps that's a lie you know I'm
telling the truth
hey die and I don't you hit me
[ __ ] now get up
[Music]
shooting craps from the alley again eh
well it ain't no use you got no more
carnal paydays
you know everything don't you I come
down here because left to give me a
telegram force kid maybe it's an
accident stop cheering
no I ain't never to open schism and yet
look you did you get her taken out last
fall all right well if you don't care
about yourself at least think a little
of me
I ain't claimed to be pushing you around
a wheelchair bun stop beefing I'm all
right watch the other ticket another
hearts and flowers cry for help
well fine yet tear it up you know done
will these teas always set this back a
few bucks
where's Rama
please to see if you see the same thing
I do will give you chance
comedy's kidding me I guess so this
could mean why do I need mention bunny
you bet I ain't mentioned the idea of
Wallace detrimental stop by it's just
poetry made of faith oh what a key
that's right it's the same show in it
that's a coincident senses that beam of
yours trying to get you somewhere it's a
lock just to shove you in the same show
with that J that's the break I guess
well you can stop blowing off steam and
cool out because I ain't going what I
said it and that settles it
oh it does when did would you say
something well I could be a big flop in
a Broadway show
yeah that's the tip you escape gank off
the nerve well I'm satisfied I got me
helped you can't have everything
yeah you won't even get help you keep on
playing these type towns much longer
all right I want you to meet mr. Howell
it's a privilege to meet you mr.
fantastic women take this along with you
and read it you got six kids get away
what's it all about
you'll find out when you read it now or
you can come back
you sure must like roulette mr. Haas I
would enter you in a customer's contest
your shows the only one I've ever seen
how's that the only chance I have seen
you how are we gonna start kidding me I
you missed our I wouldn't have to do
that now I was no way of playing
probably you're out in those theater
papers funny they have somebody thinking
about you that you don't know nothing
about sit down figure this out in
Wyoming you got any family lonely my
sister
you can never marry no but I'm hoping
awful hard I'm going to be
I'm Mary
oh yeah yeah I'm dragging the old
ball-and-chain around what I'm sorry I
was getting ready to put my foot in I
know you would
that's why I stopped you
do you want me to think that you're wild
No
I just want to show you something about
marriage I hate you
and if I know anything about men you're
as fine as they come not knowing a thing
about me you're willing to marry me if I
wasn't cool and it means something to me
but all I can think of is it goofy
coming upstairs
sliding all over the state he's a
student sometimes I think he doesn't
give a darn about me he's all I can
think of and you know what I'm doing now
I'm using you to see if I can make him
jealous when he comes in here that's
what marriage day maybe it's not married
maybe it's love
well whatever it is pray that it never
hits you now I've got a feeling love
don't have to be the way you say it is
well it's got to be that way with me
good I'd only love one man I've got a
hunch I'm never gonna feel no other kind
of does how do you drink
thanks a will we don't drink to you yeah
me the fact
this is my husband huh glad to meet you
thank mr. Hollis ma'am it's been sitting
outside every performance for the last
three years I know what was it is that
me no no I just found something I like -
well I mean a bad idea that lie yeah
guess I'll be going it's been a Oh been
a treat to meet you folks
good man good night well you're a fine
piece of Bologna are you gonna start
again well what is it now oh you're so
wrapped up in that Marco game they can't
even see what your old whites do it come
on I'll buy what are you doing
I suppose it don't mean a thing to you
to find your wife like this greeted with
a strange man does it well as far as
that goes bond I seen you more undress
than that on the stage and drinking with
a strange man ain't gonna hurt you
unless the hooch is bad oh but I can't
do that damn don't do that number my
time you got wise to yourself that's
right ride me ride me
well you don't care what I do okay kid I
think you've always got sense enough to
take care of yourself and that's a darn
sight more than I ever had where would I
get off finding fault with you mom boys
snap it up get that makeup on you got
just 20 minutes to get out of the
theater you're fired
am I going nuts what is this way of
course still the only way I can let you
off mr. friar yeah I have just got time
to make that New York trip
say maybe there's something wrong with
that Lucia after all I'll never forget
you that's all right kid it's all for
the sake of heart
there's two ways to take that crack you
know but this is all a lot of hooey I
can't go away without you use your thing
lefty can't afford to let both of us go
decide if they don't treat you right
I've still got my job yeah maybe you're
right
write to me often kid
are they awful lonesome without you I'll
be an awful step without you bunny
maybe two should be a big flop like you
come back soon
you can't come back your fire yeah never
taught a debt that ain't so good oh
forget it honey
it's sinkers no I don't like the way you
say sink well how do you like the way I
say swim well here's our backdoor kid I
can't take that we saved it together
it's yours as much as mine and I don't
need it honey you take it I don't want
you to be short in a big town all right
kid I'm always going to keep this poodle
bag it was the first one we ever had
wasn't it yeah I'm the others a long
time before we had anything to put
Nujood in me
how be a fine-lookin SAP landing in New
York without a clean shirt don't think
I'm doing a trap pack don't think I'm
scared darling because I ain't but I
wish I wasn't going I will feeling we're
making a mistake yes the day I've been
dreaming it for four years
nice kiss day boy you're going to New
York and you're gonna knock on coal
they're gonna see my use boy they ain't
seen nothing yet
well I guess that's all
I don't know how to say goodbye darlin I
never said goodbye to you I love you
I'll miss you yes I'm lost already
without you Bonnie
funny number bunny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wherever you may come to me signify Roma
I am LD beautiful while the music plays
on ladies of the dance with by like out
of the door
in the minuend a like a viola
eight made and what the speed on top
but of you now
as the more exciting fashion that they
ordered or
this young miss can keep pressure hard
in spite of the wind and snows when she
does that you trust clot down where the
blood flows there's a great appeal to
the real they go for on air inside
that's one reason why Irish eyes are
noted for their smile this can never be
really up-to-date review
if you didn't see
into what the Hindu
look at this and all
if you wanna know you are all in the air
and the dolly ther if you like addy
a lot of
here's the day Dede
any kind of shattering four of you
prefer your cladded we seasoned whether
you today
here is something sweet
ladies
wherever you may come to be dignified oh
man
and if I am handy but if you are out to
make a hey on you on a shout if people
Rea this is how it's not
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for the use of the hall
I want you to meet Miss Meredith this is
good Johnson your performance is
marvelous it was so funny
thank you she was funny it's just as
gorgeous personality yeah you were grand
tonight honey hurry up kid you're going
out in society tonight I'm glad you
folks think I got by all right
[Music]
the edge from skid yet you have nerd
phone since he left heaven when I wrote
him about the heaviest fear I heard he
was having with Mac or we didn't answer
got him to give up the day or I finally
old papers didn't answer that either a
dirty [ __ ] you must know our show is
closing well I guess lefty if you did
you can struggle on without me oh yeah
then I'm looking up in New York I'm
gonna give him one last chance I should
say yeah I read about your clothes I'm
gonna be in there by I thought maybe you
lined up I ran down to see you may I
carry your suitcase where you going
your Olympic gonna be in there next week
they are calling your life
so Jamel bit you and then hangover glad
this one's finished well I gave a
performance tonight even yourself baby
as long as the audience lab I'll get by
on guitar but it's another Heights and
flourish cry for help
what's your hurry
[Music]
[Music]
what do you want to see this let's just
get Johnson please you ain't here would
he have me no really I'm not your
guardian angel
I'm mrs. Jung oh I think about me
Johnson I do you know if you got a
telegram and evening yes you got him
probably find him at Tony everything 63
West 49
thank you
what's the name please did you jump
your missus kid Johnson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and all the guys been well it's about
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh great to see you again
Oh dumb as ever
hey I've been looking for you for three
days where do you bid oh I've been down
Atlantic City on a big party and I had
done nothing but referee fight attorney
Bonnie curls like I shouldn't get mixed
up with nice people here too rough boy
who's the cuckoo Harvey huh little
brother Atomics is he here yeah we're
leaving for the West tomorrow
boy you're a lucky girl and what a man
he is you read about him but I always
thought you had to die a sin before you
met one what's the matter I can't help
feeling that Harvey's getting the worst
of it
yeah I'd rather die than give a guy like
that's the worst of it you know what's
the matter with you bond you're still
crazy about skin well maybe I am but I'm
gonna forget it why never knew where I
was at the skids never a day's peace for
four years but I gotta say I was happy
with him but I made up my mind I wasn't
gonna be a mug all my life
I made up my mind of his time I found
someone who do little worrying about me
found him didn't you
say they got a brother oh gee I'd love
to get out of this business and go move
out west Bobby said there ain't very
exciting in Wyoming you can ride all day
and never see a soul but come on out
we're discussing I'll give you a swell
horse yeah next winter I'd have to eat
the horse
[Music]
hello its skin when I do same thing you
done to you
hang up oh I couldn't do that send him
up girlie cross which you do is nobody's
business you may get a big kick out of
wiping his nose and you're me we have I
got small blocks or something I don't
know
how'd you could you let me know you
always here let me have a good look at
you well how are you
oh you in the pink if you notice
anything you look like it tomato
surprise
and I suppose you couldn't come alone
are we afraid I do do you
we don't wouldn't want me to shake these
guys would you tape it with me all night
yeah I suppose you're king of a
nightclub now bond stopped writing me
yeah you've been crying no you can't
fool me
I seen you cry too often what's the
matter
take the new guy treating you right I
suppose what happens to you is none of
my business I suppose I'm gonna forget
you're the only girl in the world I ever
give a darn about yeah me and how many
others I got tired of being a mob scene
how about that Marco day or a sheik cold
turkey cheese just like old times
well I got your little love note hate
squawkin
I'm sorry well--there's up crackin at
each other and has some fun I didn't
start it I know you didn't it was all my
fault
I was only kidding it you know what
could stand being kidded my oughta know
better
hey ba what are you gonna marry that big
breath of fresh air from Wyoming I can't
get married till I get my final
screening
what are you going to do - laughs I'll
be nice I know those Dame's they want a
Wally insider to show business she
probably asked new club Erlanger was
never really married well what's the
difference as long as they love each
other for anybody all people have to do
is just love each other and get a little
sleep
in a hospital
Gangu village
I never seen any Bangaru you see the
sign gold Andrews
don't you mean kangaroos thank you Miss
Honey a spelling bee am de are you and
Bo is dangling sure you want to stop by
oh I would
lady
well I like the two kids from the West
where she god
what's the matter what her better alone
she'll be all right in a minute I didn't
do nothing did I what could be dumber
than a calming room hey bunny bunny come
on out what what's the matter oh nothing
I used to love that Oh number that's all
yes something different something hot
[Music]
yeah having a party you remember here oh
yeah all right I hope I didn't stop the
music
won't you go on I'll be delighted
well I don't know any of the new songs
my favorites are all old like in the
gloaming bunny sing that for me whoa
come on sing it funny yeah sing a bunny
I bet it's great
Oh
we
[Music]
yeah nice and gay why don't we celebrate
in any way a wedding or a funeral
shouldn't we be toasting to bribing
saying gay did ease with the groom
well I wouldn't have spoken about it if
you hadn't missed it under the
circumstances that I wanted well and my
good porch except to assure you then
it'll be my aim to make life happy for
Vaughn and I am sure that you'll be and
her husband will be glad to know that
sure I'll be glad to know it why
shouldn't I be glad to know that Bunny's
gonna get along all right without me but
what I'm saying is why can't we be gay
about it and why can't we have the
wedding march played with pepper and
ginger and why can't I be given the
bride away
what's a better right to give the bride
away it shows there's no hard feelings
why do people get char and crab when
they lose out in marriage
why don't they join in the festivities
monteri playing wedding march playing
man Gary its attention wedding and here
comes the minister here comes the bride
here comes the groom
here take this man do you take this man
I do I do I do
take this gal you think this pal I do I
do I do to love and obey we do we do
[Music]
[Music]
the show's on no way no way you do
realize you'll be cat the show dawn
Harry go away from
well how did it go any better
how did what go rehearse will you that
hit get wise yourself lefty you can't
put over a show without comedians well
then I got comedians I don't know have
you don't only a wisecracks get out
the lid fan of yard cost me another
touch well wait a minute send them
here 20 bucks if you think you can keep
sober 1 get yourself a room take a bath
and be at rehearsal at Bryan hall at 9
o'clock in the morning remember
no booze this is Friday the 13th we open
a week from Monday in Patterson so pull
yourself together and think up some new
stuff I'd be
remember I'm countin on you you know me
lefty here I know the fireman's child no
we were riding so far I told you it's
gonna be a long ways bad have a nice
ride Bonnie did she's just crazy about
horses crazy over horses horses before
horseback riding something you've got to
cultivate yeah oh hey the telegram came
for you Bonnie
I have to go party selected thing you
sure you do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's right that's wrong my mother
might loosen up and show some death now
this number is supposed to be a Wow say
I'm [ __ ] your ears and listen with
you I'm talking to you now roll your
eyes when you do that in twists make the
boys out front think it's real and smile
smile be in the movie is the way we
faked it BAM stop yeah all you have to
do is roll your eyes with these yokels
and they take it personal
what goose men are all right all right
cut off the gab and now we're flying
again
alright alright that's much better why
don't you do it that way in the first
place
alright girls you can all go home I'll
be back at 7 o'clock now don't forget
this is opening night
well did you find him
yes where is he well that's the sad news
I get him to the phone I'm buying the
tickets and when I turn around he's gone
you dumbbell you want two days for a guy
and when you get them you're run away
from them well there ain't a chance for
him will this last friend there was a
boy he's all shot you're a cheerful guy
hey if you was a wise fella let's put
bows on the front and get your show open
tonight I'll run along like a nice girl
gutsy I won't need you and bozo to seven
o'clock yeah well you've only to thin
the show I never gonna say one of this
uh he comes to buy these things all the
time I don't know what are we gonna to I
got plans
Jimmy I got plans and I got a headache
go beat it with me hey fun gee it's
great to see you
how I have acted Oh am i it's just
another world that's all well what's it
all about
it's good I can't handle him bond and
being a big brave guy well I I wired for
you to come and help me well I'll do
what I can
I'm even right now no matter what
happens to this show how long can you
stay just until the kid gets on the seat
then I've got to join Harvey in Chicago
we're gonna be married there hi Lefty
am i early yeah but tomorrow you are
I've been waiting on the ferry for that
guy Jimmy here we showed
who is that
and my same things
she's still there
you see lefty why sure I see it don't
kid me
I haven't seeing things lately
okay fine
hiya kid I mean have a good look at [ __ ]
hey woman crying no I hadn't hey you
can't fool me
I seen you cry too often we're done on
this dump be king you know I'm wise mr.
lefty mister lifting of [ __ ] togethers
rotten show off me he caught you out of
the grave it wasn't exactly the great
well don't waste another minute around
here honey
I'll open alright nobody has to worry
about me
you know me skip the firemen's childhood
I'm always there cure y'all come on
you're different
are you shame to me funny no having an
opera sadly don't ride you will your
body does I made Adam - right honey
I'm wishing there's so many lectures I
carry my old slide
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey where's this guy you take cut
Bernard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's out I guess I better call off the
show we don't do that lefty I'll get him
on honest I will how I don't know this I
will all right one I'm countin on you
get me some more
you'll be alright honey you'll be
alright
nothing can stop you
you'll be all right honey you're nothing
cold you'll be all right you ain't
started yet you'll be all right
well you got him all right
yeah but I wouldn't let no totally gets
to the show
[Music]
what are we gonna do when he comes to
the slide he'll never make it he's got
to make
[Music]
but in Katy don't you you better get
those are ready to go on in this place
never thought he'd get through that he
gets through the next number maybe all
right
[Music]
[Music]
are you coming ready
think you can make it I can't
[Music]
good I guess it's like the guys better
for me worse for you
[Music]
No
you
[Music]